we are going to be speaking with
stephanie kelton who's a professor of
public policy and economics at Stony
Brook University and one of the world's
leading experts in modern monetary
theory unfortunately due to a technical
issue as I would call it we lost the
first bit of the conversation with her
so I'm introducing her to you now and
we're going to join the conversation in
progress if if Mitch McConnell and the
Republicans have decided that you know
the four bills that have been passed so
far that's enough that's sufficient
we're going to close up and go home
we're not going to do anything that's
going to add to the deficit further
we're beginning to worry about the debt
and you're gonna leave state and local
governments out to dry you're gonna you
know there's a number of other things
but I have to tell you that's the one
that concerns me the most because you're
already hearing governors tell you
they're very candid about what the
consequences will be if they don't get
aid from the federal government they're
going to start cutting the public
workforce firefighters teachers police
officers essential services everything
is going to be cut and it's going to be
cut deeply they're going to be 20% 30%
cuts more layoffs and so what Congress
is trying to do to put some kind of a
floor under the slowdown and you know to
provide some support for this economy is
going to be completely undone when you
get 50 little herbert hoover's running
around all over this country working
with their state legislatures to slash
budgets so now along those lines we the
unemployment insurance system these are
state systems which are being there
independently operated some you know you
file by phone some website the systems
are sort of functioning to different
degrees depending on how overwhelmed and
modern they are we've got the federal
supplements for unemployment insurance
of up to $600 a week we're starting to
hear that there are state governors
saying we can only really maintain the
state benefits for so long before those
run out as they say what is your
perspective on what needs to be done in
that sense well a couple of things the
the mistakes have already been made in
the sense that once you allow people to
become
unemployed then the way that you're left
to deal with them is through
unemployment insurance and the the thing
that happened after the Great Recession
you probably remember is that people who
went on unemployment insurance then have
the unemployment insurance that period
of time runs out and then it expires and
now you don't have anything and then you
have to go back and Congress has to
fight and negotiate and pass a small
extension and then it turns out not to
be long enough and you got all these
people who became long-term unemployed
26 weeks and more many people were
jobless for a year or more in that
environment and the benefits run out and
all of the associated problems so it
would have been I just want to say it
would have been much much better to have
an effective paycheck protection program
in place that allowed employers to keep
hold of their workers keep them on
payroll avoid letting them slide into
unemployment and then have this system
which as you described is antiquated
you've got people who are reporting that
they've made a thousand phone calls a
day to try to apply to get in the queue
for unemployment insurance so you know
what happens when it runs out well I
guess we we hope for the best in terms
of Congress being willing to extend
unemployment insurance as needed or
people are just going to be left with
with no income at all and that's
fundamentally I mean that's how it would
have to be managed right it would have
to be managed where the Treasury says we
are going to fund these state programs
or we will make up anything that the
states are unable to pay that's the
mechanism right and that's we've just
been just yet that's exactly right
if what you have a situation where the
federal government sits in a unique
position as the issuer of the currency
it can't run out of money state and
local governments completely different
state local governments can't issue the
US dollar they are users of the currency
which is why every mayor and every
governor essentially is pleading with
the federal government to come through
with grants with aid to help state and
local governments because their budgets
don't work like the federal budget and
so that's exactly right and
where revenues are collapsing at the
state and local level and state local
governments are dependent on tax revenue
to pay the bills whereas the federal
government isn't the federal government
is going to have to step up and write
the cheque or we're going to end up in a
situation where you have mass layoffs
across the country state public sector
workers and essentially states that are
unable to bear the burden of supporting
the unemployment insurance system I read
a paper yesterday that argues that this
is actually going to be much worse and
last much longer than certainly the
administration is willing to admit when
they say it's going to go up like a
rocket analogies to Great Depression
number two my question to you is what
are the indicators we should be paying
attention to to determine whether that's
the direction we're going or whether in
six or eight months there could be a
significant portion of the losses
recovered I mean I think we're watching
the unemployment right I think that you
know you you can extend loans and say
that they turn into grants but you're
still we are still relying on businesses
to apply for these loans to take some
risk because it doesn't cover all of
their fixed operating costs we're
essentially saying you know do us a
favor help us keep people on payroll but
we're gonna cover some of your fixed
costs but not all of your fixed costs
through this profit go through this
process so businesses that have let a
lease they have rent they have utilities
they have other fixed costs that they
can't cover because they're shut down
they don't have any cash flow right they
have no revenue they're not going to
take those loans and keep the workers on
payroll if it means they also have to
incur a bunch of other costs that won't
be covered that's going to come out of
their bottom line so watch the
unemployment rate and watch how many of
these businesses are essentially going
to be gone forever and that's the really
scary thing as small businesses really
are the backbone of our economy in terms
of you know supporting jobs and you know
I talked with people I got a friend out
in Kansas City and he said
a few weeks ago you could drive around
and you can see signs in the business
storefronts that said temporarily closed
right he went back a few days ago and he
said the signs no longer say that they
just say out of business you know
they're boarding up they're going under
so I think those are the kind of
indicators that let you know that the
kind of thing that you just said that
this could be orders of magnitude worse
than the Great Recession and we could
end up with an economy that is deeply
depressed for a long long period of time
yeah here in Boston we've seen a shift
from open for takeout and delivery to
closed until further notice which is
sort of another sense of that couple
other things just to talk briefly about
before I let you go one is the stock
market this is looking at the level of
the Dow tell us anything relevant right
now well it tells you a little bit I
suppose it tells you that investors feel
less pay okay about the degree of
commitment on the part of the Fed to
help maintain stock market prices I mean
I think it's a reflection of not so much
you know fundamentals what we call
economic fundamentals the health of our
firms and the likelihood of a solid
recovery in the months ahead but sort of
confidence and a belief that at the end
of the day the Fed the Fed has your back
I guess the question is whether that
means anything for Main Street as they
like to say because at a quick glance
you see the unemployment numbers and you
see the stock market doing okay it
doesn't make sense now a lot of that is
how bad was it expected to get when
people go on unemployment they do
presumably get some money which they can
spend which could prop up stock market
there are other factors but how does it
relate to the average person's
experience and outlook not very directly
at all yeah I mean that's that's the
thing you know I think investors really
are mostly channeling optimism about how
far the Fed is going to be willing to go
to do whatever it
takes to protect the largest
publicly-traded companies and
shareholders last thing a universal
basic income there is a movement now so
universal basic income
I guess as prominent as it has ever been
probably mostly thanks to Andrew Yang's
candidacy in the Democratic primary
there are a lot of conversations now
which seem to go along the lines of hey
we clearly can afford to do what Andrew
yang suggested and we've clearly
determined it's a good idea we being I
guess you know our legislators lawmakers
others saying there's really nothing
here these are extenuating emergency
circumstances these are one-time
payments even if it's renewed one more
time this is not universal basic income
and it does not affect the economy in
the way that a ubi would what can we
glean about ubi from this if anything
well I mean the the twelve hundred
dollar check a lot of people are saying
just keep that going and that would be a
form of you know a basic income payment
again even with the twelve hundred
dollar check there is means-testing not
everybody is going to receive that check
with the yang proposal remember that you
know that proposal was tied to a whole
series of offends so if you want to opt
into this program then check the math
and make sure that if you're receiving
other forms of public support if you're
on food stamps or you know yeah there
were a range of public programs that if
you're a beneficiary you need to decide
whether you want to continue to receive
those benefits or let those benefits go
and take essentially what's behind door
number two with although I think later
on it became changed to be additive
although I don't know I'm not
remembering no no no no it was additive
in in the sense that if you're not on
any government program okay you get it
if you are on certain government
programs like Social Security
it was additive to that but it wasn't
additive to the whole package the whole
programs okay so but look a basic income
right now or in
I'm supplement to people makes perfect
sense to me makes perfect sense to me in
this moment that you need to get cash
into people's hands you got all these
cars you got thousands and thousands of
cars of people families lining up at the
food banks right people aren't at the
food bank because the grocery store is
out of food they're at the food bank
because the bank account is out of money
and so in in this situation direct
payments on a recurring basis for a
period of time make make perfect sense
to me you don't necessarily think this
tells us anything about the long-term
idea of ubi no not really I mean look if
we just did this conversation where I
said suppose we were in the fall of 2019
yes if we're in the fall of 2019 and we
were talking about sending every person
in this country which there is a
proposal Congress congresswoman Rasheeda
Talib has a proposal to send I think
it's $2,000 right every single person in
this country for a period of time now
that's a universal basic income payment
over a period of time
suppose we had talked about doing that
in the fall of last year when the
unemployment rate was three and a half
percent and I think that most people
would have said there's your inflation
invitation right because in that
economic environment people had jobs
people were already have you know had
income to spend and on top of that
you're gonna layer for 8,000 per
household depending on this number of
people in the house I think it's a very
different question in that economic
environment we've been speaking with
stephanie kelton professor of public
policy and economics at Stony Brook
University Stephanie really appreciate
your time once again thanks for having
me